eastern Mediterranean and we have three
speakers for this panel and followed by
commentary buddy up our own Rashid
Academy and i'll just give very reseed
reactions to turn to the paper the first
paper would be by our operational who is
professor and chair of history of the
Arab world publishing and he's published
extensively on eastern autumn and invent
Iranian studies including work horse
racing down free volume work on this
dream world pal silent which I think
this problem would be apart of and so
today we will present Valley and
discussing the Cold War the question of
palestine and I think he's also promised
to take the story have 33 80s which is
something that hasn't come up very much
the part and then move here from Nora
Anchorage who is research associate in
chair of contemporary history also at
the collision Falls and she would speak
she would be the first paper of two on
the Cold War II back to Syria and after
that we'll have a talk by a civilian
phantom who teaches history of the least
and economic history of developing
countries and international relations
give me a title of Venice respectively
and he's presenting some work based on
his latest published monograph which is
really odd East German administration in
fact this area thank you so I under the
leaf of his approval professors decade
of so his we spoke yesterday about
Western question as a pattern and just
one more ID was still doesn't claim a
political insight was to understand that
Zionism could exist and achieve its
project only by winning the support of
one possible with powers in Spanish and
of political Zionism so Middle East
record one is talked about yesterday I
don't come back to this point and of
course Sally Athenian and Zionism it was
always hostilities and steady forties
just a few momentum so on World War and
relax after a registry na us discover
one of a in central aspects of a
question of palestine which will which
is the contradiction between domestic
and what interests 1v1 and
the address that must be secure in the
Middle East and the other hand for more
land electron reasons Roman was led to
ship what most of the zealous claims we
were absent in the logical conclusion at
least a bit beginning as a result mainly
Metro crisis in the privilege l'chaim
shea relationship is no better than the
United States through indeed we could
raisin London accuse the White House of
responsibility submit that in its
Palestinian policy very when I for a
long time a first Palestinian world
Featherston water is a unique case in
the war contemporary history of an air
paste or the outside process where under
one side and miss only fuk opieop
occurrence during two hundred years
remaining Britain expected when Jenna
pseudonym bamboo and did that survives
of allies with abs in spite of it
resists for the way home so late Indian
unless ur extent France provided westjet
of his tiny house despite their bamboo
and the u.s. brought the diplomatic
support to a new state while seeking a
political solution to the conflict the
bigger Asura in geopolitical terms was
Britain which became popular in both
Israel and our country's its capacity to
act was not very doin ships from the
same reason when I was a Soviet Union in
which wasn't popular West was upsetting
we're naughty comedies with our work
after its nightly 48 per se maybe too
many go with
while yesterday so Russell and in the
50s what's the question of onions
history leaders fear the most was but
Westerners might make political
concessions were out with respect to the
Palestinian issue in return from their
integration into Western defense system
with Angela closer will be eyes on our
end the discussion less committed to the
journalism but spread Assessors and we
have to act according to result of state
wherever I can British when constructing
elaborate plan it was not well received
by other players involved for the most
what is some part of the pan and Millie
disclose too many so negative consensus
has often there are some the Israelis
found themselves together in a negative
consensus which we could not open the
Express they feel bad from the control
of unburned like full vertical but of
economy the Westerners might impose or
tight control on man was limiting the
pressures in the balance which we had
recently acquired or food they were
hunted in communist countries do not
want to improve at your hostility of a
Soviet so it was the question of the 50s
1955 about our worlds Verma friend came
by that act conventions between us
yes and Egypt 1966 for crisis reward
American project collapse why the single
drug study conflicts in impending which
create some confusion among American
British leaders when we French aligned
himself with his telescope and Levi
lighting the Western regulation of a
moment or rebellion miscalculations led
to serious crisis to his crisis and what
I'm sorry struggle for me the race
chipola plan good master but a tiny was
from 1957 to 1965 the pressure thus
Palestine was in a way push into the
background of struggle from Middle East
NASA contained two and kind of and from
an agreement with the Americans and the
discretion in the icebox we've got used
isolation is in the icebox in the
opposition between perhaps progressive
leaders and the Conservatives will say
listen was above a rhetorical argument
first NASA line umpires inside listen
and reaction the conservative leaders
responded to his attacked by underlining
necessary
elections we forgot to restrain the
sector equal fighting was also used in
the internal opposition between the
progressive letters Egypt Syria and Iraq
it was the alcohol so another time sorry
from 1964 attention that will is turnin
is our neighbors increase here again the
Soviets for noon full of the movement
rather than provocative it it was
provided Egypt with a means of
sustaining the world in email and
memories with Miss Treadwell at seeking
to probable crisis we talk about fume
Elizabeth also present implication of
the u.s. beside Eastern and distance
from Europe at this time registered
email with an imagined of superiority
which was in central to set universe
survival estate imply the strongest
earnest report in front of original
aesthetically the US alone guaranteed
belonged and security of diversity of a
state of this trial whether Jake have
awakened choice was to be found in the
American domestic political life raft of
220 life to Reverend in the apparatus of
right parisi more aware a direct
military intervention in federal destroy
was impossible in the context of the
Vietnam War II still have to be strong
enough to be able to do
well to direct American military
dimension Jim 1967 was most bothered i
hearing one of the reasons follow it and
see at issue the risk i doing back panel
for this conviction of despite a minute
I success the US would not bear it any
territorial expansion as we show during
the sizes prices but the Johnson
administration without pre or thinking
to the photos decision of living
offended possibility of annexation after
a political settlement respect of
territorial integrity was for us to be
established after all not before this
sacrament it was on this dying basis but
the ambiguities of recession 242 where
establish that was sure but she was how
the condition with reputation the
conflict over several decades were
created so NASA vegetation movements are
ahead of time and missing time this
process just shut pro trust in the
situation over three years worth 40 no
bcuz that increase missile
identification and we're making home
deliveries to Eastern Washington
elevating the heavens as a vast global
scheme of Soviet expansion in variation
and the same time the sewage in yet
presented with arguments with
negotiation is a surface took place
during the first years of a Nixon
administration where the us consider the
Soviet position are most of the most
extremist Arabs whereas men to the
direction to the lines of June 45 1967
unless the measurement of an estimate of
non belligerence very early American
diplomacy undermine the necessity of
place in the legal sense reward with
diplomatic relation between estrela
under our countries we must not included
in various in addition but was was in so
short of a political consensus in
Washington was to reach a political
settlement which would exclude the
Soviets or event for an operation to
west bank became possible well first one
was or just me emerges I did you
advocated a global climate we would
reduce perhaps needs and you use the
Soviets was also releasing marriage
under the influence of an attack the
second one was us but a fire Kissinger
which consisted in museum is trying to
finish their apps for using the Soviets
while suggesting but us alone had the
means to obtain from his time master
settlement we would be acceptable to the
ABS so the to question the standard as a
strategic asset during Black santander
crisis and the time to discuss the
question and act of 1973 and it was when
Simon Says
for Kissinger line of no keys no world
and circuit unit was frost to Michigan
and in the world but imagine don't want
this work so it was caught in the trap
maybe I can pretend a friend to release
fish under the condition of a political
settlement why Moscow are dubs that's
about the capacity of MMA's coupon for
this time as a result the Soviet action
we're polite which increase the apps
lack of comfort in his no business
situation the circuit at to resign
myself to give it a chance never made so
we'll watch in the world in which we
live and which was provided without van
they sent disparate signals to Americans
about the necessity of putting an end to
the no peace no war situation which only
reinforce my conviction of excellent is
usually but the political line of action
was steady at again so every one of the
step-by-step strategy its basis was the
fact we do perhaps whoever they were to
accept political consequence of the
process triggered by the world principal
of territory star face on the
normalization of elation with his tried
negotiating we were away again hello
perhaps to avoid the decisive step while
destroying one the possibility of silly
me enough time to establish his military
superiority in this context of the pond
while winner was of us which made Egypt
swing over to his side and now Jimmy
Carter
and those of Egypt we will trauma for a
distant rock and leather and the best
nineteen twenties Graham a situation the
partner of crisis the protection of our
monarch is Ivan Peninsula have been
different divine since nineteen
thirty-five as an American national
origin terrorist and as a measure of
component of a difficult relation
between businesses ancient us so the
original revolution change everything
while radical Islamism and both of
soviet union of us as enemies Wilmers
deform the American leaders proved
unable to understand the new context at
the time Weber end of a Deadhead mud we
start a new phase of a cold war with
President cutters Pearson creation of
rapid deployment on task force men to
protect the third countries the question
of determining the strategic asset miss
repair is trying to try to have
Americans been a party at the capacity
to send his forces infatuation but we
have never managed normal legitimacy to
whom so under culture a japan jordan and
the political capacity to Atia when it
was necessary to provide value
sorry Hammond a moment so that's my
patient man Reagan administration with
informal strategic consensus between
Eastern and we are on as Jordan wishes
to agree with David across agreements
American members of Congress refused to
grant Jordan becomes he asked for
question the Central Command in 1983
this time was excluded from it country
to a japan jordan the US was admitted
that military relationship between
family straight could only be military
on the strongest technology and
intelligence well concern and
Battistelli not really expect to play
the role of strategic asset the road
which was a certain extent was supplied
by mobile acts agent which knew how to
reap the benefits of steel strategy
position but this did not really matter
because the cement a relationship
between us and historian lighting the
cross in notification of the two
countries for cultural and religious
reasons when the bills friends of
history and constantly client battery in
boost it was indeed a strategic asset in
the cold war and the dissenting voices
were not listening to really matter in
the world 1982 was presented lesser
anticommunist whoa and so getting a
methylated by accelerating seriously a
moment it was the last important
work infatuation we've got back set was
four star general which traveled with
claiming quite claiming to still play a
role in the political settlement a
purely focused a distraction was mounted
to the Soviet Union during the metal
components in nineteen eighty one
conclusion the superb fact but the
question of palestine existed before
before work can continue the one after
mix the importance of this world
watching deliver less record well
establish the region as a space of
containers from North political
competition after the period of British
et money the grip for were swept again
cooked in the 19th century logics of
government in defense the instant
mission whitening the question of a
settlement into the interest in central
stink once again pushed himself as a
major player average in the Soviet Union
tried to obtain an account between the
big powers under political settlement
moon stone then the his capacity to have
an influence of advanced condensing
leave a major proposal reunited state
was to eliminate that influence and two
ways damage the interminable West at the
part of the world in order to do so when
we can kept the amazing peace processes
which always came up against the same
difficulty namely Americans with
capacity to have interference on the
choice of his tribe receiving
appointment with the Soviet Union makin
any commentary add two halves partner
did not allow it to a benefiance
domestic sources abscess Edison was
essentially a domestic one and the
Soviets for was Adam with a capacity to
have an influence on the statistics
choice of a para partners the idea of
the Soviet expansion establishing
popular they requested that I serve the
Soviet Union was associated with a
different vision of the West the Soviet
never had the means and therefore our
ambition to do soon mag member against
the web a prisoner imbalances there were
many more were probably like civil and
military add without any real political
compensation
yes I we started a short representation
of which we try to be so with a quotient
of French diplomatic vessel American
Thomas licinia who say the American
diplomacy is a garage to fix the United
States don't understand anything at all
they seen saiah Soviet satellite like
poems they haven't understood national
is dimension of the salient government
this retrospective analysis my skin
rather harsh but whiskey describe this
world American Legion of this country
where people also during the War of the
bus Sally as a Soviet Union were
intimately Buddhist over the
relationship was much less by complicity
and commercial goods then by
misunderstanding and diligent omissions
to borrow an expression to patricks here
since tyler was a roller coaster my age
marked by image ups and downs to
understand his relationship with a
select units at this time i would really
hurt started damascus began to get
closer to get closer to Moscow from 19
and 55 on Martha after its refusal to
sign another part committed to resisting
convinced expansion in the Middle East
seller did so less because of a sudden
sabbatical Soviets suddenly goes it's
late decision
transposition but when retailing and the
US and courageous toolkit concentrate
troops and she has border the master
decided to turn to Artemis cool we've
seemed to have the same objectives
indeed boss were looking for security
Sicilians thought for protection of the
planet and they move their neighbors and
the foreign colonizer white recipients
thought for four prisons is distal
military in southeastern Mediterranean
to protect the black that is a black
keyboard from the original build-up of
American power more of our lives in West
block so so let's quickly understood
that you've been friendly terms we still
have as I had to respect its neutralist
nationalist and I said I'm
anti-imperialist feelings so susan has
contact with the Soviet Union became
immersed in the relatives economic
educational and military and above all
in our transfers which actually cement
his relationship at the same time the
u.s. became convinced that Celia was bad
leak under which becomes a satellite the
Western is Talia about your community
cover insignia was so that's what
Americans Mount Isa Veritas Pierce least
try to your photos
this part of this conspiracy visions in
fact Sylvia never even came close to
becoming a satellite say let's pass
these leaders especially Hafez al-assad
always remain wary of collision at home
they certainly used of the Communist to
back up some of the receipt offices like
progressive reforms in the early 1960s
1960s which aim and which aimed after a
witness in traditional poverty class of
shields and their lives to Muslim
brothers who set sets himself up as
responsible for the uranium we have the
traditional social order they also try
to use for these idols to fight against
religious special it is lung which
represented the main enemies of our
report from the late sixties onwards
onwards for example in ugly 1967 Sgt
Jesse Schell people People's Army
publish an elopement article which
describes new man by his terms Saruman
believes lives as a god religious
feudalism capitalism imperialism and
also values which founders are also
slightly other women filters good for
the museum of the story we don't need a
man who preys good news down who begs
mercy and peace in the world the new man
is a socialist and propulsion system by
no surprise the publication of our
provocative huge hangar movements and
loose impressive words of school for
striking Homs Hama and Aleppo which
lasted four days so indeed the basis the
pieces are sometimes used the community
stands an artist but even when they give
us I never forgot that they were
dangerous rivers convincing herself of
the same theatre by no doubt the Soviets
who are applying the situation they were
also pretty much abrazo applications
andrea has a year together an
arabic-language sets of most of the
basilisk officers had nothing to do with
nationalism also shall soon but after
this period of look no matter clearly
not ridden in a relationship between the
mouse cursor in Moscow to events and
it'll be profited change of climate to
two words of 1967 and 1973 after 1967
warm up Cena like Egypt wanted to
reverse that as a relative total defeat
and begin its lost territories my first
of arms if necessary while Soviets were
interested in meeting me you notice the
water church
the US side indeed they were afraid that
an action which could lead to a
confrontation with a little luck
furthermore or settlement able to
decrease as a dependence of the
Massachusetts affiliate support those
there was neither military agreement no
no coordination between the massacres
and no something from the outside of the
world and so it was between Cairo in
Moscow the solids provide exterior with
aren't you defend itself from any
Israeli exactly but no advancing with
weapons to be used to defeat as well as
his position first sounded to be rooted
for the basis of his sir's wanted most
was held against Britain or the Marines
Special unsubscribe but they also did
important for any interference in the
original Ottoman stop domestic policies
nevertheless they weren't too happy
about the Soviet intervention with the
u.s. to go to cross a red line when this
well after capturing the goal makes a
sweetness to work on the message after
the defeat official Assad as a time
cosmin Easter conveys must come to a
creeper to the train's coming including
the Air Force which have in their
destroyed during the conflict the code
there is a corporation with the Soviets
grew a poison us and three years was
introduced reproduce it almost
eliminated basically said that they can
he be dependent on the Soviets it was
still took place when i SAT sites for
were in 1917 obsessed but was preparing
for war did his best to reach that
purpose introduced and visits to Moscow
to say crew from the Soviet all the
airport but it was always tough handling
to get what he wanted actually the
Soviets for supporting with promoter a
blow to Israel which my dream ver this
way leadership to the conference table
but certainly not one leading to an Arab
to other of victory during the nineteen
seventeen seventy three warm like during
the previous one the servant positives
that despite with the situation of no
peace no war which which seriously began
to another sales metrics say that pretty
much aware of this select opposition I
had already taken measures to bring down
with Moscow notably by expelling similar
thousands select military advisors and
women expense in 1972 after the war
decoding is in themselves that only the
newest put heaven so it started normal
for peace process
wester that was regaining was a u.s.
damascus and most also religious leaders
to kiss to consider him as a traitor and
as both were aware of the dangers as the
peace process represented for the bone
interest they got closer again in 1974
ring ring greencove paid a visit to
Damascus and as I visited most works
highbrow at the same time as that was
willing to establish some sort of
balance between the two several summers
sense of extra stirring his relation
with which was achieved by Kissinger and
Nixon see the dumbest person I've
selected for in fact acid was pretty
much wherever to so it's very reverent
inclined to give him to give him what he
knows parties so it is lost territory
and that they weren't able to understand
this foreign policy like his
interventional to ask to risk of
Christians in Lebanon in 1976 even is
good even his new personal relationship
with honorable which had developed in
italia the threat of related common aims
basically the destruction of the israeli
balanced agreement shortly after the
israeli-egyptian one was too short to
lead to a perfect virtual perfect
approach as I quickly realized that God
said will not be a loyal ally that his
predecessor
having those from the mid-80s on Mars is
a relationship between most point and
the mass crucible cooler and cooler for
all those associates were cheating to a
position of the neutrality is a
arab-israeli conflict decided to restore
them military support this was a bitter
blow to Damascus long-term strategy at
holding this valiums like to sum up
observations the relationship between
the massacres and Moscow even in our
moments never let your protectors and
and never even began closed to me like
the us-israeli relationship to conclude
as to briefly about the cost per asleep
theories and the prosperous Alicia's
Lewis ontario's as i said the American
Spencer had a conspiracy vision of the
relationship between the last cruise and
Moscow at that time they saw in cydia
but you see a satellite most of the
others which had little or nothing to do
with the river ring which is select
block a quite common collector the
Americans had a kind of hysterical
perception of the treat as a time when
we say that this conspiracy vision shape
it safer when diplomacy dismal more than
the facts and the and the events
themselves as assumptions is the use of
the conspiracy theories my business
salem's indeed most of them is
Evans were over always presented in
under another cool world light two
examples are eloquent I spoke earlier
about your article the Newman completion
in 1967 is about his tremendous yourself
and which promoted a huge for the
struggle strike led by the Muslim
brothers in most of the cities of the
country it's interesting to see that to
carry out the situation so st. journal
published a few days later and over
article in which a salient posterity
explains that the previous article was a
plot orchestrated in order to establish
original insane the writer answer editor
of this article as Sen a ages this
article in terms of fruit up an
israeli-american trout that part by
matters of religion and travelers of the
revolution in order to open the goals
between the people as a people as a
leader the second example is about their
positions which are Lisa Muslim brothers
who led the opposition against a
passivation from outset during an
official SS rule they were
systematically accused of being the
right hand with a unit of the US and out
there Israeli device used to talk about
fascist regime and to destroy original
revolution as I did so in 1979 after the
attack on Joe out here are tonight's
cool 11a two days later the information
minister stated after the tragedy of the
Battle School the Israeli sent us his
message investor wants to control the
domestic situation issued per game users
this despite land yet inviting members
of the Muslim Brotherhood led by hand
Hamlin o clock claimed a responsibility
for a possible attack they also did they
also did so in nineteen eighty two
eighty two after the Hamasaki a two days
after the end of the fight Hafez
al-assad staton everybody knows that the
Muslim brothers are manipulated by the
Americans and their Israeli the line at
how about they gave the huge army supply
and we show this Arsenal on TV I didn't
find
pictures yes this piece of work so these
advices leaders truly believe that in
this so-called collusion is if it going
to save the new methods at times they
have many enemies who had good reason to
support an internal insurrection in
order to destabilize the region the
region notably Iraq an angel important
in terror of revival reasons in any case
they refused to organize officially the
existence of an internal opposition they
certainly used for those conspiracy
theories to back up a propaganda which
aimed to fight a new engine isolation
and to keep to justify the revolution
reserves in the of the internal enemies
who represented the threat for the
regime were hugely important partners of
the US and there is rarely a lie muslim
brother preserves bassist erected near
archaeal engines nah serviced with
exception of needless to say jessalyn
Kerr minister dr. Kelly sacraments
enemies actually it was slightly more
difficult to convince people that they
24 Americans right but this didn't
prevent buses from giving the community
same heart treatment those basis menus
of the Cobra rivalry in a terrific event
was probably for the use of the
conspiracy service in a lot of Sicilian
too late
domestic policy which became
increasingly difficult to defend wise to
Erebus movement which had been to panera
of basses and western beginning to
channel them from the early 70s of wars
I'm sure that body Special Reserve will
be very proud and confirmed in believing
that is that the world turns around the
great affirmation and the under the
leadership of syria since the desert and
Syria to do to vegetation anyway me I'm
general in particular specialty is the
relations and the politics and economics
offered the true german is the west
germany's easier during the 60s and the
early seventies and well wishes first of
all we should another over States
overestimated the role of Syrian in the
cold war in the sense that Syria for the
chickens always came second in the
political agenda first was edgy age was
main asset the syrah came second was
relevant for things but always came
second anyway Stalin serum I is useful
for some other odds and the to Germany
connection with Germany's already in the
since he was talking about economic
dimension the Cold War and the
competition is unrest throughout the
world and as for the Germans and the
German called war inside fatiguer pigeon
they had their own peculiarities first
of all the word forbidden from any
direct military of major political
intervention growth it could not which
work again and they put but they portray
themselves as changes of two different
patterns of modern development here the
eternal modern development i mean the
basic establishment of the nation-state
the central nation nation state is the
main political unit on the one hand and
the other on the other hand the
industrial develop the task development
is the main way to create wealth and to
foster social change within the new
society that were the best and the true
german is shared more or less the same
the same theme however they differ for a
rather relevant aspects first because
with Germany change on the free market
economy has the best model but she fast
and self-sustaining loaf of raisin roll
and such an Isetta stretch the lead you
to improve completely
and the local comparative advantages
both in the domestic international
market whereas the GDR had a different
view of modern development and this in
this sensitive perfectly endorsed the
ideological framework provided by the
theory of the non-capital is the road
development which were developed in the
19th development approved by Moscow in
1961 and we should provide a viable
model for third world stage as in the
road to development and the positively
socialism and this model basically
advocated for the primacy of authorities
over economics and the words conceived
as a roadmap to independence and
socialism but for did from so-called
progressive forces the forces of the
national liberation and the
revolutionary forces and not for the
other anyway to develop advocate is the
centralization of state administrative
and recursive apparatus which should
which will consolidate the progressive
control of society and the challenge the
conservative forces and the later must
be marginalized because with our
tightest Western imperialism and because
they would oppose any way social reforms
and as well as the Train national
national resources away from from the
dancer and then particularly the state
should be strengthened to become the
main agent for domestic development
social change the state should be the
main tujhe and well anyway more or less
taking to some of the similarities of
the truth models to butters of
development made by the Germans they all
share some common features anyway so
state power announced announcement
reliance on technological progress and
investor is asian and they shared even
one peculiar aspect is it is the
relevance of the training of education
training and education as since program
more or less majority was equated with
the instrumental rationality as well as
we capital the social mobility and
different and when they were both
frameless frameworks remain to be the
meat of technological progress and the
irrational efficiency and actually the
two german is completed rigorously in
the fields of vocational education and
technical training in Syria as well as
other for the world state and allow you
even with many other bodies German
official considered seemed to advocate
is it is training for work with an ethic
based on discipline spirituality and
poverty the three pillars of agents
trained is a crucial to the process by
which the post colonial leaders and a
further world working class would learn
learn working order in
and how it should work this model anyway
there were even many differences first
anyway the to model the two camps to
German is also very different financial
and technical conditions for trade the
loans and scientific cooperation and it
was particularly relevant for those days
like series head and not the resources
like Iraq or other countries to pay in
cash the same for the machinery for
education and training and so on but
then there was another difference that
was the very political one that means it
is they addressed very quite different
social groups whose claims and the big
ambitious increasingly clashed with one
another and here the basic question was
who was to govern the process of change
the process of development and who goes
to mainly benefit from this process of
change and develop and what kind of
pattern of development should be
invented and projected accordingly and
that I decided of the word anyway even
if the Chi German is conceived the stage
is one main dealer of development for
the GDR among the state worker it will
the main engine the main channel through
which development was to be projected
and implemented whereas for western
Germany was just that in the state was
it an element within a more complex
feature work anyway the free enterprise
would be the main agent of of
development and growth but this did work
in Germans what the Germans vote but
going back to the series
curing me you know i started a serious
Syrian politics in the front of beer /
1963 which is when the path power the
bath party its power to the to the early
seventies and the discourse this period
was called a particularly after 1966 the
the Bureau of work the Radical factions
of Syrian parties to power professor in
a bushel Rosa booking were doubled this
part of Syrian history head as esta mas
cosas SD annoy of the Middle East at
least was the hopeful and now they are
faced it's some sort of regional unity
of regionalism and with the panel with
the pan-arabism coupled with aunt
imperialism and the support for
revolutionary the liberation movements
throughout the world but as a matter of
fact they basically translated and here
I mean really the concept of the
translation as a theory there's a
practice in a brain even by
post-colonial phosphonic critics really
crucial to understand anyway that is
translated basic pillars of modernity
within the boundaries of our of the our
cultural heritage shared practices and
and history in fact in their case they
plan to concentrate power within a
nation state based on ideology and
collective party institution and they
conceived industrial development as the
mainland enjoying to copper powder is a
revolution with taru it is well and at
the end of the day there was a basic
convergence
in baddest Syria and the socialist kind
particular leader is Germany whereas the
War Department divergence tymberlee
diverting say between Syria and western
Germany last time and so the question is
what first were forced to face the
reason and here we just heard some of
the main point the serenity is found
themselves that themselves at odds with
Western Power first because of the
articles were an accountant who remember
the ninth listen tried over nineteen
sixty seven feet and they told the
soviet socialist tampa for military
support political backing and strategic
thanks as a former and the late mr.
industry serum sound design told me was
not the soviet union was the
intermediary and the guarantee for
national independence is a bit addicted
over of the West in the region so arms
the library mood to a profitable
business and almost unconditioned
political support but there were other
reason for this convergence because as
soon as the part is staged a coup d'etat
in 1963 and they enter in a bitter
struggle for power against the
long-established ruling elite of Syria
which mainly whose social and economic
background could be fine fine the fam
mainly the human marriage and Families
some religious authorities so on whereas
the particular ability the leadership of
the bodies the bus party after
6066 all had very rural background did
they they they came from the problems
they came from the profit center all the
books dates and about outer world about
the biographies of all those really
amazing just show confirmed his
dispatcher and so the TDR and the East
Germany provided those bodies with
institutional and the organization of
framework with the machinery the tools
to wait that war against the the
previous established at ease so for
example they they provided the state
machinery for the provider experience
their expertise to reform the state
machinery and the state apparatus from
from introducing central planning
economic central planning to wait to
marginalize or to carve not the channels
of tray enjoy it and control by the
human to human merchant families they
the German disturbance provided their
expertise to reform the security of our
other than colorado abroad look what was
the took its origins back for two to the
frames to zen below but that in the late
sixties and seventies was reformed and
shaved according to the East German
secret service from so from December 02
stars in her eyes it is stated security
they introduced the doctor use of the
dogs sir Christian breathing ok and a
but it even as for the party if the
other party to use another
but important the sum one element of the
bath party was preformed a cook along
the organizational framework of the East
Germans Socialist Party is DJ I have and
in the words of I interviewed former
present deputy national secretary of the
road the bus party knock knock who told
me well that does it why did you choose
that model this is a party instead of
the HP dating and it's only work because
it will work with some problems for this
right operator a confident but first of
all first of all because the socialist
party with Germany controlled every
sector and every layer of society and
that was what you wanted that's what you
want and again here it's not that they
just copy come on they translate that is
they select those features and
translating that into their reality
taking work what was better for them and
I think that this is packed deserves
quiet attention because it or not asanti
these work about our national reason
wrote about it on sale ok that's a old
all the wine in new bottles but the
shape of the bubbles in this case the
party state can affect matter fact even
the taste of the work
and even the identity the identity of
those forces and how they portrayed
themselves and how they present
themselves up to the outside world and
anyway at the end of the day the tdr
provided the parties the Baathist regime
with some institution which is to a
certain degree an upward social mobility
for those groups for those groups okay
the lights peasants state employees
workers just a certain degree which
could work for business until then it
work Oh Bernard an esper ideology will
didn't really pay much much a great role
just made here information one sentence
reported by the GD GD our experts
talking with the president use of a time
who's one of the closest allies of the
history of the socialist can and well I
call the president use of a sign put
believe that e equal to get rid of the
Labour class and the Syrian communists
from one day to another just like you
throw from a man is a sick blood and
inject him with you let's try the
digital anyway so the key concept want
to share with you are about these
experiments are the basic notion of
modern development in the sense of
establishment because consolidation of
the nation-state in developing countries
on one side and the spread of the start
the project of industrial development is
they remain enjoy too
to rise growth growth and even to change
society but but that was it the project
that is back to Muhammad Ali would be in
England and the first concept second
another concept we serve deserve much
attention even if to say but certainly
for today politics announcing the region
with a pack of diversification this is
the Cold War as for economics were
concerned proof of the very existence
that the certain degree of the socialist
and provided in alternative market for
for those states like Syria we said did
not have much money to pay for Western
technology that was the difference with
Iraq access to technology access to
educational and professional training
then that's crucial a whole range of
leaders and state officials when to
study in the socialist camp and were not
were not all communist towards our
system not at all absolutely so then the
functionality or any way of these of
these relations in the sense that we
heard about opportunism right the truism
like the way the former Eastern and
bassam German ambassador I talked to we
said what was married to convenience but
given the contractual innate nature of
marriage I said who gained involved and
said well the series of course first
because the healer is much more than as
an intended we didn't get back our mind
first of all and at what it was a
marriage of convenience anyway in the
game mode and second again another
concept very important was the transfer
and again the translation all ballistic
to
organizations and frameworks from the
east to the Syrian okay I'm keep you
awake I see people some people are
sleeping not I'm sure because of these
talks which are tonight to meet me it's
riveting but is it so cold it's that
terrible hour after lunch um I found all
of these papers absolutely fascinating
and i'll just say very few things about
each one i gather i have 10 minutes okay
um all i want to say about unease paper
poster which I I was in complete
agreement had to do with I think you're
basically accurate is basically accurate
analysis of how domestic and email
polity or result they thought interests
went in different directions and I think
this is true both American and Soviet
all um the only time I can see it in
Soviet policies at the very beginning
after some Union recognizes Israel and
Golda Meir comes as ambassador to Moscow
and the Soviets suddenly realized that
Zionism is very popular among a section
of the Soviet population when she's
received rapturously in Moscow and that
triggers all kinds of
responsive Direction talk about your
talk so here you have a case of gravity
coming started it's not really does have
any sense of the domestic situation or
any some design is it were just doing
what he's doing for rail quality reasons
which several people talked about and
yet then comes this domestic and I think
that that that downs against further
Soviet support for Israel it's obviously
most clear the American pulse I don't
know the Soviet side well enough is the
only case i can think of in american
policy comes up again and again again
again the first instance is truman who
is strongly advised by his intelligence
professionals his military advisors by
the State Department not to send an
anglo-american commission of inquiry not
to vote for partition not to recognize
the State of Israel and again and again
does things entirely against the advice
of his advisers and says in one stage he
brings a group of the State Department
friends a group of American
representatives in the Middle East to
Washington to me that the president
keeps awaiting for several weeks the
heads of delegations in Cairo and
support because they're told the
president thought would be a bad idea
for him to see his state department
Chiefs from our countries before an
election vital election it was New York
was the key there's a key election it
was actually a mayoral election New York
State and when he sees them he says he
listens to what they have to say and
according to the report of one of them
he says gentlemen I'm terribly sorry I'm
not going to take your advice I have
hundreds of thousands of constituents
who are concerned for the future of
Israel and I don't any arrows ago thank
you goodbye go back to your post and we
see this constantly in American foreign
policy not just over Israel that's
approximately almost excessively
mentioned that this is a domestic issue
American we've heard America and the
Mafia and Italian dimeric on domestic
politics in Italy mention anyone knows
anything about
entirely well no this is Joan anybody's
watch the last two weeks of Egypt will
know the American public when it gets
excited about something suddenly asserts
itself and God help all those rail
politique policymakers who love to do
their business and dark words that never
have public opinion effective suddenly
forced to deal with the fact that the
American people want democracy or in
this case the American people want
science or whatever they want the IRA
whatever it maybe they would want and so
this is this is a constant I think this
is a constant a constant in foreign
policy especially spur country like this
and I haven't suggested it's a it's a
constant writing any liberal democracy
if you go back and look at palmerston or
other especially little british foreign
secretaries and pointless to the length
and century they have the same problem
um last thing i would like to say about
on this paper um is i think you
accurately talk of that how the domestic
element operates it is obviously much
more important much less important under
Eisenhower and then it was under Kennedy
and Johnson and people have ascribed
this to the fact that either Eisenhower
didn't have to worry about Jewish voters
for Kennedy and Johnson four degrees or
more or more to to certain other
domestic issues that may be true but as
you correctly contact once Israel is
able to pose as
credibly claiming to be a strategic
asset there's absolutely no difference
between the public administration's from
that point on until the cold war Israel
is not solely able to sell itself in
terms of domestic politics but in fact
primarily sells itself and its domestic
lodging are useless ferociously as an
unsinkable aircraft carrier against the
Soviet Union in the eastern
Mediterranean has a great strategic
asset the Cold War if you know that
cartoon where the roadrunner or four
different one it is one of these cartoon
characters is running along which is the
end of the cliff and keeps running and
that's what happened at the end of the
Cold War it was so many belong and
suddenly there was no Cold War there was
nothing to be strategic asset for it
didn't fall it caught the war on terror
and proposed as a peasant as a strategic
asset but that was not a terribly
credible and actually I'm waiting to see
somebody pick up on the fact that
there's absolutely no strategic reason
for the American Israeli relationship
there's a domestic reason there are
shared values there are any number of
things that history related but there
are no certificate which in fact was the
case back in the forties liberties and
into the 60s was until after the 20 more
in fact the strategic pretext or
argument otherwise I have something else
to say but they're very very very
trusted paper Nora's paper I found
absolutely fascinating um and I agree
with everything you say about
the United States exaggerating the
degree of identification between Syria
and Soviet Union although listening to
today messy messy a newspaper and the
closeness between the party and the
intelligence of the development models
you can see why Americans made a mistake
and they thought that um I think that I
think that you've quite accurately both
of you in fact talk about the different
aspects entirely different aspects of
the relationship between the Soviet
green and the bath ratio but I would
make a distinction between the so called
neo life the people who came to power
starting in February 1966 and can rule
until November 1970s are called how to
keep a one when i said carries a coup
after the party censures i said he
basically announced the party the back
party CSIS drool Syria in fact with the
crew of XM between that period and
everything he follows there are they are
quite different I don't know in terms of
the development or they will cover for
the party relationship but i do know in
terms of foreign policy I said after
that point carries at the foreign policy
that's much more can be congenial to the
Soviet Union I'll come back to that when
I talk about your paper about Norris
paper just two things um I fully agree
with you that the back regime said
absolutely anything to discredit his
opponents these regimes will say
anything or saw this the last example of
this was the extraordinary alliance of
Hamas and Israel as agents of the
opposition to hoboken regime
exactly as logical is what the Bison in
fact they're identical any liars our
lives I respect they'll say anything to
stay in power however of we don't know
very much about but know a little bit
about the fact that the station of the
CIA in did have deep-seated relations
with Muslim Brotherhood which was had
its headquarters after it wanted to
exile in a number of these countries in
Western whether this was directed
against Egyptian regime only whether
this was directed against the Iraqi
regime whether this was directing is the
Syrian regime all of them are none of
them I don't know and I no knowledge of
any archival sources on any of this um
and I don't know that they had any
specific relationship with any specific
action that the Muslim brothers may have
taken in Syria so I don't think that the
CIA instigated the how uprising or
anything like that or that anything can
happen SN said if that was true
nevertheless I would be slightly careful
about this these are things we find out
about only from memoirs and whereas we
have some memoirs from the Afghan war
period and we have some memoirs from the
fifties in the 60s were late 50s early
60s five America from American former of
memories with the intelligence service
I've never seen anything about the key
period the word
we're all interested in I only know that
during the Afghan war these old networks
were activated well where were they in
the interim we don't know where they
completely dormant was there no
connection I don't I'll be like a few
doubts are you playing no better than I
proxy good the last the last thing I
want to say I think you're absolutely
right but not only the Syrians but also
Egyptians were infuriated by the Soviet
unwillingness to support them in war up
to the hilt um then you also talked
about this and you're all you're right
you're both right about this um and I do
with you something that I just have
arguments about people in bed back in
the day when there still was a Soviet
Union there still was a cold war um that
the Soviet ian was afraid of United
States and this is the main reason they
did not want their clients to confront
an American client not just because they
thought the erect light would rip their
clients as it had done again and again
again but also because they were afraid
of confrontation with a superior
superpower that would humiliate them so
they would not only be humiliated by
proxy by having Soviet arms again showed
it to be a courier to American armies
but they themselves as a superpower
might be humiliated and that takes us up
to the DEFCON 3 and the 73 boards or
something I will say one last thing
about this that um that um the Soviets
really were genuinely afraid in here
he's losing and this was i would guess
probably not just at the top it was also
instituted within my military within the
intelligence service and so on somewhere
i remember talking to a Soviet official
who told me about a military of military
active military technician an officer
well had a nervous breakdown on an
airbase in Syria after sanman makes that
he and his colleagues and painstakingly
assembled on the they've been created
floated on a big unthought of freighters
whether they call transport planes put
together and then the Israelis bonds
with the man had a nervous break and
that kind of frustration with how poorly
their clients had performed in 56 inches
in 67 better during the war of attrition
and much better in semi food I think
colored not just the people at the top
and the marshals of the red army but
right out of the right last thing about
Norah's paper yeah about the Syrian
intervention on in Lebanon it was a
problem for Moscow for many many reasons
partly because of other Soviet clients
as it wasn't just intervening on behalf
of the baronet to the Christian Susan
convening against globe in his national
woman Soviet client the PLO Soviet
client and against the witches of your
another Sunday client so basically it
was a disaster was a no-win situation
the last thing is in spite of the
coolness in Soviet Syrian relations to
write about at the end to the Soviets
still offered a guarantee or certain
territory when the Israelis were about
to attack too late they warned Israel is
not to attack secretary and they did not
is this is what the immunity back up
said invaded publicly before he said do
not expect it so the unit will intervene
on the side of the p log or the lebanese
naturally there's nothing we can do
Israelis only in the country we
typically tell you now we can do nothing
Syria is different so oh I'm sorry I'm
told I have to stop
I had a whole bunch of things to say to
them the only I'll say one thing is that
okay I'm sorry on in spite of the
closeness of Syria to the Soviet Union
in terms of the developmental model of
industrial different development in
spite of the closest in terms of the
secret service in the party especially
at victory at last period there was a
contradiction during this period because
this was the most revolutionary the most
radical the most unpredictable
adventurous regime except Qaddafi was
never control or predictable that I
think Soviets ever had to do and this at
the time of the height of the
sino-soviet ideological issue so these
were people that the Soviets on the one
hand probably had a closer ideological
relationship to then anybody except the
South Vietnamese in the Arab world and
yet they were wounded I mean they
sincerely believe you start in our
illusion by provoking Israel I'll police
they'd seen the Arab future in Algeria
people's war of national liberation
worth that's not a Soviet comes that's a
Chinese concession and the Soviets were
horrible at em pen and zaria and marcos
and the generals who are aligned with
them believe Taj HD they believe this so
this is terrible contradiction that's
nothing to do with what you're really
talking about but it's the background of
all
at the same time you have the party in
the same time you have what up and sit
down you have this development model
which is the same guys are very pleased
with you have these wild man in Damascus
dragging always practice exceed in
interactive opportunity to the 67 one
sorry